I would say the F the [__] Russ era
obviously all that kind of that was that
the only time you actually had an artist
physically do harm to you or is there
anything we never heard about well the
Russ didn't do anything it was his guy
right yeah I was just like at the nail
salon around the corner from my store at
the time and I remember it was some kind
of like goth boy click event or some
[__] like Jesus that sounds like that
sounds like a terrible thing so
basically you have like a shitload of
zand out goth kids hanging out at the
store right and so I dip off at one
point I go around the corner to the to
the the nail salon and I'm getting my
nails done and I thought oh I'm gonna
put my hood up and I'm gonna face away
from the door so that nobody can tell
it's me not a great idea didn't see
these guys coming and then I just hear
at one point Adam 22. wow get punched on
the side of the head and I like fall
down for a second like I think you hit
me one more time and then I jump up and
by the time I jump up they're out and
you didn't even realize it was connected
to Russ until later right I didn't
realize it was connected to a rust until
like a year later when academics was on
live stream with them and Russ said
something like yeah that full item 22
got touched too but like that it was
breaking up on the recording of the
stream but AK knew what he said so act
told me he goes this is what Russ said
and immediately Clicks in my head like
oh my God the Nigerians because Russ is
always talking about his Nigerian homies
and [__] and I'm like oh my God those
guys were Nigerian like I got beat up by
a couple of Nigerians that Rush sent
through and so then all of a sudden it
made sense and I remember I sat on it
and thought about it for a couple days
and then one day I was like you know
what I might as well just use the [__]
for some clouds so I just go on Twitter
and start being like hey [__] Russ
hey I feel like I feel like his um
campaign of beating up rappers that talk
[__] it worked right because nobody says
it no more and I feel like people now
are like yo maybe Russ was onto
something when it came to being
independent and like owning your Masters
and not getting [__] by labels right I
mean what I will say is that Russ
definitely like didn't do himself any
favors around that time he was just
saying a bunch of wild ass [__] and just
kind of disrespecting a lot of people
yeah I mean he had that t-shirt
um that stands out when he dissed all
the Atlanta producer or whatever and I
remember South Side was going crazy on
them like he made a lot of weird
decisions around that time now that
being said I and the reason why I kind
of let it go and just decided like all
right I'm gonna just be cool with Russ
when you initiated the conversation is
because Russ brought it up to me that
there was a lot of tweets that I didn't
remember probably because I was zand the
[__] out just like his T-shirt said
where I was basically like really
roasting this [__] and I don't
do that now like I'm not gonna just use
like a wrapper as a punch line like in
the way that I was doing there where I
was really like treating him like he
wasn't a human being you know which to
me I don't I don't approve of that to
condone that I feel like you should
approach everybody as as a person and
you know try to engage with the actual
ideas that they're putting out there now
if I had had some angry tweets where I
said Russ doesn't know what the [__]
he's talking about with these Atlanta
producers or actually Xanax is the best
how dare you insult Xanax right then
that's fair like that's me having an
opinion right but me just like clowning
him and just treating them like a joke I
don't don't really condone that so I
have to even though obviously I don't
condone you know him sending people to
beat my ass either but I do respect that
you gotta respect the shooter at the end
of the day or the puncher you can't
dictate how people react to disrespect
yeah and I shouldn't have been lacking
anyway it should have been like because
man you imagine another version of that
story where I pull out the thing and
just bow and then you smoke two random
dudes and you're like and you find out a
year later it's not going to take a year
the cops are going to go through their
phone and be like oh [__] Russ sent
these guys to do this and then I mean
that's the alternate like realistically
that's how that story would probably
play out today so I'm kind of thankful
that I learned that lesson early on